according to legend 30 years ago Atari
buried truckloads of videogames in this
desert welcome to you guys thank you for
coming out we really appreciate it
we are going to start digging in a
minute our goal is to find some evidence
of the burial of Atari products down
here in Alamogordo we hope we'll find
the et game we have not found anything
yet alright it's day two of our coverage
of the Atari excavation they have
brought in the media they have brought
in the public and they've brought in
winds that are supposed to get up to a
hundred miles an hour from the south
today
blowing garbage dust all around this
landfill the Illuminati of retro video
gaming have come out for this historic
event so we are going to speak with
Howard Scott Warshaw he is the designer
of ET we are going to talk to video game
designer and historian Mike mica we are
going to talk to Ernie Cline he is the
author of the incredible book ready
player one they are here wired is going
to talk to all of them today as we dig
up B Atari treasure trove of legend for
a company that's really in dire
financial straits to take all this
inventory that's supposedly worthless
and literally truck it out into the
desert and cover it up with some that
mash it over with tractors the kind of
thing to do with nuclear waste just
seems absurd it seems ridiculous on that
level I always thought it can't possibly
be true and here it is I mean we're here
looking at the excavation which I've
never really believed the stuff would be
here
when I was a kid I read this story and
it was almost mythical to me because why
would a company like Atari dump so many
games so I'm here to kind of complete
this 30 year mission of mine to find out
what happened to these games if they
even exist what's this thing all about
the video game crash and kind of the
death of Atari it was all linked and
blamed on ET the video game I played the
hell out of ete and thought it was one
of the most innovative Atari games of
the time
been here for a while already it's
sincerely morning that's the morning
it's tedious the winds horrible but one
day they're going to find anything or
not because I'll just taking up lots of
trash and everything it's going to grow
smelling right now at the moment if that
bucket is any indication
seems like they seems like they found
something we see a lot of smiling faces
- bringing some stuff over to the
archeologists Nemo right now zach is
about to speak let's see what's going on
we found an intact et the videogame et
is definitely here the legend was so
awesome like it's kind of a shame to
finally figure it out right like I think
it was almost better to be The Legend of
what it was when I first baked these
games the whole point was about
entertaining people like this right now
behind me it's still entertaining people
now it's no longer a legend right now
it's a fact everybody's standing around
here because joe said they're there well
so yeah again I wasn't nervous till we
got down to that where he's almost
reaching his max land well yeah it was a
big weight on my shoulder one went out
that bucket came up in there then he
tees
not just asteroids
here we are I'm actually holding one of
the et cartridges that was pulled out of
the landfill it was it was a legend in
the video game industry for three
decades and now finally we can say with
absolute certainty that it is true Atari
was really buried out here in the New
Mexico desert
wires brought it to you first thanks
guys hello there I'm Howard Scott
Warshaw designer of yars revenge Raiders
of the Lost Ark and ET subscribe to the
wire channel for more action like